we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
we are not screening calls for topic but
we do want name and where you're calling
from who's next on the line with me
hello on the air no i'm calling from
oakland county michigan great what's on
your mind um i saw just a couple days
ago um we um specifically the post
election polls and just how it's very
out of the ordinary that the losing
candidate Hillary Clinton many of the
exit polls in different states she's act
she was actually winning so I'm just
asking so do you think that you know
there really is a you know good cause
for skepticism about these results
especially based on the fact that you
know sold time Trump was saying the
elections can be written everything
against two or you know the fact you've
got Russian diplomats that are saying
that you know they were making daily
contact with the Trump campaign yet this
is a really messed-up election right so
if you take all these pieces separately
okay Russian diplomat has said they were
in touch with the Trump campaign that's
very very strange we know that the
releases that came seemingly involving
Russian hackers absolutely benefited
Donald Trump and hurt Hillary Clinton
you're also bringing up the discrepancy
in some major it some important states
Pennsylvania and Michigan and Florida
etcetera where the results were outside
of the margin of error relative to the
exit polls in those states individually
by itself maybe not that concerning but
combine it with these other issues we
also have the issue of voter suppression
where if you look at states like North
Carolina uh and and Wisconsin and some
other states that that we've discussed
and you look at how since the last
election restrictions were removed in
terms of what the states can do in terms
of early voting and voter ID etc and lo
and behold
turnout from non-white and/or
lower-income counties went down
significantly if you put all of these
things together it's very tough to say
that that this was an election that went
forward in the most honest and up and up
way individually you could maybe
discount the impact of any one of those
issues but to me altogether it's pretty
funky yeah i mean i would definitely
have to agree with that especially you
know um you know in the past trumpet
said you know for instance how you know
he doesn't for instance he doesn't know
putin he's never talked to prove but I
we thought there's actually footage of
him actually saying that he's had both
direct and indirect um um contact with
Putin and you know the fact that you
know this is somebody who is you know
cheated people his entire life right
whether it's in business or you know
whatever you know I just it ripped yeah
we've got you've got a known scammer I
know a known scammer will be taking
control of the White House there's no
doubt about it it's absolutely
undeniable thank you so much for the
call i really appreciate it hope to hear
from you again